i was just gonna say just in the time
shirley was blabbing her religious
preach i actually did some business and
i think if you check downloads that
westboro baptist church right now you'll
see a nice message from anonymous so
hold on
downloads.westboroughbaptistchurch.com
yeah we just we just put up a nice
release while shirley was preaching
there just while we were doing this
interview yeah we just yeah we had
enough i mean we responded maturely we
said no we don't want to work shirley
came on the radio started
well her thinks i'm going to hell so
we've given her something to look up and
can we you think that if you try to do
something to us because something's
already been done check it that you have
to oh but i don't don't you understand i
have to talk that's my job it's somebody
else's job to look at the websites it's
not my job so hold on i am getting a
thumbs up from my producer that there
has been a message posted that appears
to be from anonymous on
downloads.westboroughbaptistchurch.com
is and anonymous are you taking
responsibility for this
yep we just did it right now this very
second